the hunt
you know the drill
predator gets hungry
predator hunts prey
predator kills prey
right
[Music]
wrong
sometimes game plans fall apart
and major screw-ups about
but the hunter who pays attention to all
the mishaps survives
now five ocean predators perform epic
fails
and reveal what it really takes to make
the ultimate kill
[Applause]
of all the fish in the sea this is the
top predator the great white shark
a five thousand pound male starts a hunt
he hasn't eaten for three days
[Music]
he picks up a scent from two miles away
seals
[Music]
he's a great hunter
but he's not perfect
great whites are unsuccessful more than
half the time
weather conditions prey reactions or
just plain luck can tip the odds
but this guy's got some clear advantages
the most significant being
lots of prey
seal island
[Applause]
it's early winter right when this 75 000
course buffet must leave the island
in search of food
it's the pups first try at swimming
[Music]
instinctual grace soon surpasses
clumsiness
they're on a mission
to get to their fishing grounds they
must run the gauntlet
[Music]
the great white waits patiently
the older and wiser seals know what
waits for them
[Music]
the youngsters don't know any better
hunger is a cruel taskmaster
there is safety in numbers
lagging behind increases the chance of
becoming a target
the littlest ones try to keep up
he can hear and feel them from over 200
meters away
in sharks hearing and vibration
detection are linked
the great white's invisible inner ears
work together with two hollow tubes or
lateral lines
microscopic pores open them to the sea
and when something moves nearby tiny
hairs are stimulated alerting him to the
disturbance
scientists call this sense a great
white's distant touch
he can smell them
he can hear them
and by his distant touch knows they're
close
he just needs visual confirmation
[Music]
he makes his move
directly below his target
then he stokes his engine
the tail is the shark's powerhouse
red muzzle sustains the swimming of the
shark
while white muscle allows for sudden
bursts of speed like a rocket booster
to launch upwards at speeds of up to 25
miles an hour
[Music]
it's a fail
his elaborate sensory plan worked so
well
he pinpointed a target and initiated the
attack
the strike was textbook except for a
curve
clear skies and calm seals like today
work to the praise advantage
the seal saw him at the last minute
so when the shark made contact his cover
was already blown
the seal's whiskers detected tiny
vibrations so he was aware of the shark
before he became dinner
the seals are now on high alert
the pups will head home in a few hours
by then they'll be exhausted
and easier targets
he slows his pace
to save energy
the hunger pangs
don't go away
by the afternoon a wind ruffles the sea
the seals are full of fish
tired from hunting
it's supper time
[Music]
he targets a young straggler
younger seals are easier to hunt
speed and agility come with experience
but he misses on the first breach
he doesn't give up this time
if you're a seal never give a great
white a straight line attack
keep it turning and keep jumping
[Music]
a great white has two major blind spots
directly in front of the snout
and right behind the head
the seal luckily lands in those spots
agility wins the seal makes it to the
kelp
double fail
for the shark it came down to one
critical moment
the initial strike didn't bear fruit and
from then on the odds were in favor of
the seal
it became an agile torpedo
using its front flippers to propel
itself away from the shark while
steering and changing direction with its
back flippers
the great white had already struck out
once today so when he missed the seal on
the first strike he should have just
swung away
two fails means he's lost out on over a
million calories
the sun sets on a frustrating day's
hunting
and the shark heads back into the deep
by morning severe weather has blown in
his senses tell him the seals are
already in the water heading out to hunt
[Music]
[Music]
perfect a straggler
he drops into ambush position
the dark upper half of his body blends
into the deep
you rockets upwards at 25 miles an hour
as he approaches impact the ampully of
lorenzini the little sensors on the
front of his snout track the electrical
charges of his target
he drives in for the kill
but something is wrong
the great white executes the perfect
attack
but there's something wrong
it's a decoy seal set by a tourist boat
to lure the shark
great spectacle but our shark didn't get
his much-needed dinner
it's an epic fail for the shark but it's
a valuable lesson on how sharks get it
wrong
most of his senses told him the target
was real
he could smell seal he could sense them
in the water
his adapted eyeballs tracked the
silhouette and he hit the mark
it looked like a seal
acted like a seal but it didn't taste
like a seal
he was hoping for blubber but instead
got rubber
the more he tries the more likely he is
to make a kill
as long as he doesn't burn out
he needs to eat one seal pup every three
days to keep up with the amount of
energy he's burning
he needs a belly full of fatty seal now
things are looking up
overcast choppy seas and murky water
perfect
no longer in tight formation the seals
are trickling in from their three-day
fishing trip
he closes in on another target
it's a direct hit
success at last
time the shark launched the strike just
as the seal was taking a breath of air
in less than a second the shark disabled
the seal
[Music]
his snout slammed down hammering the
upper jaw with almost 400 pounds of
force
he can rip off 20 pounds of seal flesh
in a second
his teeth are like saw blades slicing
off giant mouthfuls
for the great white all systems must be
accurately aligned for the perfect
haunted
every seal he gets fuels his machine the
ones that get away
motivated to try again
if the great white is the killing
machine of the sea
this predator is its counterpart in the
sky
[Music]
gannets are air-to-water missiles
plummeting at 60 miles an hour for their
food
now they're leaving to track down a
fishy feast
200 miles away millions of sardines
start their annual migration
the sardines form one of many massive
clouds of fish called shoal to follow
blooms of plankton
it's time to fly or die
the sardines can travel up to 37 miles
per day but the gannets can cover 300
miles before refueling
their bird's eye view means they can
look for dark moving water a sign of
fish massing together
unlike most birds their eyes face
forward giving them binocular vision
they see them
or so they think
they were hunting for sardines but
instead they've got a shoal of thousands
of mackerel
bigger more challenging fish to hunt
the shoal is at least 30 feet below the
surface
the gannets prepare their superpower
they climb to almost 100 feet to
maximize momentum and gravity
they have to be perfectly aligned or
they will die on impact
wings tuck
feet stow
then
into an arrow shape
most objects at this speed and from this
height would hit the water like it's a
brick wall
but the ganex cut right through it
protective membranes cover the eyes and
act as goggles during the dive
the beak is strong and pointed their
nostrils are internal preventing any
water from entering on impact
the thick skull bone is a crash helmet
and air pockets inside are like airbags
cushioning the blow
[Music]
the gannett's momentum drives it 30 feet
below the surface
the mackerel bunched together making it
tough for the gannets to pinpoint one
fish
there's strength in numbers
and then the ball descends deeper away
from the menace above
the gannet has two options go back to
the life of a bird or transform
into the awesome superfish
the gannets won't give up instead these
birds turn into superfish they flatten
their wings and swim
they can reach 60 feet while holding
their breath
they close in on the big ball of fish
the gannets grab hold of the mackerel
but their plan of attack isn't working
the mackerel are wriggling free
despite serrations near the tip of the
gannet bills good for gripping slippery
fish
[Music]
the shoal retreats to a hundred feet
deeper than a gannet can die without
running out of air
it's
a fail
the high dive was perfectly executed
within seconds the fish were under siege
but when they grabbed the prey
the mackerel slipped free
mucus covers their thin skin making them
hard to hold onto
the gannets are tired from the lengthy
flight
and today the strong swimming mackerel
proved too much for them
then the entire shoal descended
beyond granite depth
with empty bellies they take to the
skies once more
[Applause]
this time they'll go for smaller easier
to grip sardines
but where are they
the gannets are now more than a day's
flight behind the sardines
they need to hustle a huge challenge for
the young flyers among them
their time and energy
are running out
while the gannets search above the water
a menace prepares for battle below
super quick phenomenally natural
and equipped with lethal weapons
it's the fastest fish in the ocean
the sailfish
the school has found the sardines
and is closing in
when a single sardine joins a show it
gains protection in the crowd but it
also joins a big waving advertisement
for food
which is why the shoal is also called a
bait ball
this sailfish feels the water pressure
vibrations of the shoal and it knows
it's big
[Music]
once it locates the sardines
it chases them down
[Music]
an army of sailfish now arrive from all
directions
the first step is to surround the
sardines
next the hunters flare their sail-like
dorsal things to startle the sardines
split them into smaller balls
then they cleverly heard the ball upward
to the surface limiting the prey's
options of escape
they have the sardines
right where they want them
but how does it track its target in this
high-speed chase
sailfish have specialized heater organs
attached to the brain and eyes
the heaters circulate warm blood to help
boost physical performance
and the high temperature of their eyes
increases the resolution for forward and
upwards vision
the eyes can then process the movement
faster
crucial at these extreme speeds
as fast as a chief sprinting on land
they reach speeds of 70 miles an hour
the sickle-shaped tail
powers the fish forward while the pelvic
fins work like rudders steer and
stabilize
time
for the ultimate weapon
is super sharp build
its needle nose isn't for stabbing
it's mainly
a slash
[Music]
the bill is so thin that the sailfish
plunges it into the sardine shoal
undetected
he whips his head to strike and then the
unbelievable happens
it's a sardine sailfish smackdown
the sailfish uses its bill to slash at
the sardines and isolate a victim
the next sailfish in line takes aim and
strikes
it's completely off
when one misses another is ready to take
its place
another fail
or is it
sailfish don't just pick off individuals
they hit multiple sardines over and over
again
as it slashes the tip of the bill can
cover 20 feet and turn through
575 degrees in a single second
that's a lot quicker than a sardine can
swim and a lot faster than it can react
the more the sailfish strike the more
they injure and exhaust the sardines
now they're easy pickings
skewering may not be the intention
but it works
[Music]
victory
the sailfish were relentless in their
attack
first they teamed up and moved their
targets into position
then they used their two foot long bills
to wound the sardines and wear them down
this first attack took its toll
each sardine was roughed up then gulped
down by the sailfish in less than a
tenth of a second
every sailfish ultimately got a meal
sailfish are superb killers with
specialized strategies but
it's the orca that takes the prize for
the craziest hunter in the sea
no other animal risks its life to get a
meal with such an outrageous stunt
it's january along the argentine coast
and the sea lions have come ashore to
have pups
sea lions are agile
but on land they're clumsy and awkward
the pups kindergarten beach seems secure
but the sea
is the hunter's hideout
the young seals take their first
swimming lesson in the shallows
as they splash in the water they give
their exact position away to the finely
tuned sonar receptors of the orcas
sound waves travel through water four
and a half times faster than through air
the orca emits a series of clicks
through its forehead like a beam
when the sound hits an object it bounces
back as an echo
this echo location gives a detailed
picture of the size
shape
speed
distance and direction of the prey
the orca has no problem finding her
target
it's getting to it in the shallows
that's nearly impossible
at seven and a half tons
she risks beaching herself
she must wait for high tide
[Music]
four hours later the tide is up but it's
still too shallow in places
she searches for a spot where the high
tide will help push her right up to the
beach
she's found one
[Music]
[Music]
she gears up to perform a super stunt
totally unique to this
pop speed is everything the pups have no
idea
what's coming
the female orca prepares to ambush her
target
surfing away she speeds toward the beach
at 30 miles an hour
it's a fail
success is determined by forward
planning and critical timing
she didn't get enough speed at launch
then at the last minute she ran out of
water to surf and put on the brakes
this gave her away and the pups escaped
it's a skill that takes years to get
right
she tries over
and over
[Applause]
in this pod there are a lot of mouths to
feed and the orcas need to eat at least
three seal pups every day
without warning
another orca launches a shore hunt he's
got a reputation as the expert hunter in
the pod
his technique is to catch a wave and
surf to the seal
he's got it
but now he's also stuck
and yet he doesn't let go
he'll die if he doesn't get back into
deeper water
how can this massive 22 thousand pound
mammal haul its own fault out of this
fix
he starts thrashing it looks like panic
but it's not panic
he's turning around
he's free
it's all about precision and timing he
caught the force of the wave which
delivered him right to the seal
[Music]
his power and fault created enough
momentum to throw him high up the beach
his expert breaching
turned into a temporary feature
but he got out of it with a technique
he's been perfecting for years
the wiggle all with the seal still
trapped in his mouth
but
instead of chowing down
this killer decides to play with his
food
a youngster joins in on the game of seal
tossing
[Music]
scientists believe this could be hunting
training for the cavs
practice means fewer failed hunts
the hunting season is short
before long the pups learn to stay clear
of the water
and the orcas become less and less
successful
it's time for this pod to move on but
another much bigger pod is just getting
started
it begins with a family of 12.
they find others with the same goals
the families don't compete but join
forces form ranks and are soon
a legion of one thousand strong
the ready to hunt
megapod
they've got 300 miles to cover to reach
their target off the coast of south
africa
what drives this obsessive journey
none other than the irresistible
sardinia
now migrating within their reach
and they are being watched closely from
above
having failed to find the sardines
themselves the gannets place their bets
on the dolphins just follow and let them
do the hard work
like their giant dolphin cousins the
orcas they use their sonar to
communicate navigate and home in on
their prey with deadly accuracy
thousands of echolocating predators
soon pick up the swimming fish
the sardine migration pushes steadily
northwards
this shoal is an astonishing nine miles
long
two miles wide
and up to 130 feet deep
in some places the shoal is so dense and
moving so fast that the fish in the
middle
die from a lack of oxygen
more than half a billion fish are
swimming towards the dolphins
it's impossible for a shoal this big to
hide from the mega pods detection system
the sardines fall right into the
dolphins trap now
the hard work begins
holding their breath for up to 10
minutes they work to split the shoal and
push smaller group towards the surface
they do it
hurting the fish like border collies
corralling sheep
under attack from all angles the
sardines stick together
but
the tiny sardine
should never be underestimated
along with vision they coordinate their
movements by reacting to water flow
when it works they avoid bumping into
each other
organs called neuromasts line the skin
around the sardines head and accurately
detect motion between themselves and the
surrounding water
as one fish moves it creates a flow of
water that provides information to the
fish next to it or behind it
allowing them to keep their place within
the rapidly moving shoal
this is how a shoal works
thousands can move as one
each individual tries to find safety in
the middle creating a mass continuously
folding in on itself
nobody wants to be stuck on the outside
the gannets flock overhead
waiting for the fish to come within
reach
the alliance is about to reach its
climax
the table is set everyone is in position
but unexpected diners show up
sharks
thousands of them
thousands of sharks are ruining the
picnic
the dolphins and gannets hold back
feeding with the enemy means they could
easily become a meal themselves
the sharks think they can collect the
proceeds from the dolphins hard work
[Music]
they bully their way in
[Music]
destroy the tidy formations the dolphins
have organized
but the sharks can't get a mouthful
the dolphins regroup
just maybe they can patch up the mess
[Music]
sharks are worked up but they're not
denying access to the sardines
the dolphins boldly focus on turning
this set back into a victory
if they don't
they all go hungry
dolphin
janet even shark
the dolphins are back to hurting
the sardines respond as predicted
defensively moving into a tight ball
close to the surface
the gannets watch the turmoil from above
they're done with waiting
hunger drives them to take the risk and
feed with the sharks
the feast
fast becomes a frenzy
[Music]
now it's time for the dolphin's final
weapon
a net of bubbles
the bubbles form a barrier that the
sardines don't like to cross
[Music]
with no escape the shoal is shrinking
fast
shark bird and dolphin all get a piece
of the action
until a newcomer completely changes the
game again
it appears out of nowhere like a
high-speed train
42 feet in length with the ability to
swallow a small car
the brutus whale vacuums up hundreds of
sardines in one mouthful
he makes the shark
look like a minnow
flicks of its muscular tail power it
upwards at high speeds
even with its gigantic ballooning mouth
creating drag
another whale explodes out of the depths
this time it's a female
she's even bigger than the male
and she needs to eat over 3 000 sardines
a day
to survive
the whales triumphed in what the sharks
initially attempted
the late comer cleanup job
the dolphins scoop up what's left
and there's not much
only one lucky sardine survives
it sees a gap
hightails it out of there
it was a surprising multi-staged
multi-species kill
with critical turning points
the dolphins were the masterminds
tracking the shoal with sonar the
gannets used them to locate the
migration
the dolphins triggered chaos and
sardines were treated into a ball the
final step was to split the shoal into
smaller balls and chase them up to the
surface
then the sharks bulldozed their way in
messing with the dolphins plan
and not helping their own cause
but the dolphins had the courage to
regroup and pack the fish together again
as a result all the predators could
gorge themselves
until the dark horse showed up
he vacuumed as much as he could before
the bigger female took over
and she finished them off before the
others cut
still the super pot of dolphins is well
fed they disband and go their separate
ways
the gannets now have enough protein to
fly home
sharks are full
and the whale did the least amount of
work for the most reward
the sardines were massacred
there is safety in numbers
to a point
but predators catch on
and triumph
especially when they work together for
their bounty
as they will again
every year
exquisitely timing their hunt
to the great migration
[Music]
[Music]
you